[Musique]
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique
sur tv 78,2 invité aujourd'hui philippe
brillault le maire du chesnay qui
évoquera entre autres le projet de
rapprochement de sa commune avec
concours ce sera tout à l'heure mais
pour l'instant j'accueille paul martinez
bonjourbonjour mieux vie en plateau vous
êtes le président de l'udps et y dans
les yvelines le maire de buchelay
également vous venez d'être reconduit à
la tête du parti centriste c'est votre
deuxième mandat on va détailler un petit
peu vos priorités pour les années à
venir mais tout d'abord cette élection
vous avez le sentiment que c'est le
satisfaction aussi le résultat plutôt du
travail accompli je dirais pas ça on a
traversé effectivement comme beaucoup de
familles politiques dans les yvelines
mais pour le reste de la france aussi on
a traversé un peu la tempête
2017 avec cette espèce de rééquilibrage
ou deux de nouveautés en quelque sorte
nouvel échiquier politique
l'élection du président macron a
effectivement un peu rebattu toutes les
cartes les nôtres en particulier et on a
dû par delà tout cela aussi j'allais
dire essayer de gérer un peu la crise
interne puisque vous savez que les
radicaux parti radical a quitté lui dis
donc c'est une année 2010 est sur
laquelle beaucoup de présidents de
fédérations éludé y ont dû faire comme
ils pouvaient dont je parlerai pas de
bilan je parlais de confiance ça c'est
plutôt jouer effectivement sur la
confiance qu'ont les adhérents en ma
capacité à fédérer je pense qu'il y
avait deux autres candidats dans cette
élection vous les avez rencontrées
depuis est ce qu'il ya une volonté aussi
d'ouverture avec des sensibilités
différentes qui s'expriment
oui il ya eu effectivement il ya
globalement une convergence sur sur les
idées bien sûr et comme dans toute
famille politique parfois il ya des
débats internes sur des choix les choix
d'alliances ou de nos alliances etc
notamment chez à lui dit puisque bon sac
historiquement on était plutôt alliés
haut et l'air et que l'élection du
président macron a fait peut-être pas
bouger les lignes en tout cas se
questionner beaucoup d'entre nous donc
dans cette perspective effectivement il
ya eu il ya eu des débats
moi j'ai milité pour un rapprochement
avec d'autres partis centristes comme le
modem notamment pour l'élection
sénatoriale effectivement l'un des
principal candidat
face à moi bertrand coquard avait été un
peu échaudé sur cette question là c'est
là dessus qu'il ya une légère division
mais le rassemblement se fera j'en ai
aucun doute aujourd'hui du délit se
situe où justement quelles sont ses
alliés la république en marche le modem
les républicains c'est encore en
discussion ce sera du cas par cas en
fonction des dépositions des uns et des
autres en fonction des hommes qui se
trouvent dans chacun des camps alors à
l'échelle nationale bien sûr à l'échelle
nationale c'est plutôt clair lui dit
n'est plus dans cette alliance avec les
l'air de monsieur wauquiez c'était très
clair de la part de jean christophe
lagarde à notre président pour autant il
n'est pas dans gouvernement est dans la
majorité il est dans une opposition
constructive comme on dit plutôt
constructive à tout point de vue puisque
les différents groupes parlementaires
u10 voté beaucoup de loi présenté par le
gouvernement
ils s'opposent parfois notamment sur les
80 km/heure et d'autres sujets qui sont
qui sont des sujets de débats sociétaux
pour le reste effectivement à l'échelle
départementale on a un département
historiquement qui a construit beaucoup
de villes ont été construites sur des
majorités udi républicain l'époque
c'était ump puisque les élections des
bureaux en 2014
ils sont centristes dans le département
des yvelines voilà on est on est un peu
dans cette logique là mais à l'évidence
l'arrivée là encore dans marché de son
mouvement
interroge notamment dans le tissu très
urbain il ya des grandes villes dans le
département où effectivement le
mouvement en marche et est en
discussions avec les membres
les adhérents udi locaux donc dire qu'il
faudra faire des accords généraux et
globaux départementaux c'est un peu
prématuré il faudra tenir compte de
l'histoire avec eux nos partenaires
républicain parce que elle est là elle
existe et ça s'est plutôt bien passé
globalement dans dans beaucoup de
communes où il y avait des listes
communes
l érudit et tenir compte aussi de
l'avenir quelque part à certains égards
et notamment avec le mouvement en marche
prochaine échéance ce sera les
européennes ensuite il y aura les
municipales déjà pour les européennes
l'europe thème central thèmes fondateurs
de l'ue dei
j'imagine que vous allez lancer toutes
vos forces dans la bataille mais comment
vous positionner sur cette question-là
de de l'europe et comment avance ne
serait-ce que les discussions avec les
uns et les autres
or vous avez raison de le préciser c'est
presque notre adn
alors vous allez dire il ya d'autres
partis qui sont européens
on est au delà des de l'européen on est
fédéraliste c'est à dire qu'on est pour
le degré
quasiment ultime la constitution d'un
état fédéral européen
à certains égards bien sûr il s'agit pas
de nier les nations la france l'espagne
l'italie etc
mais on considère que pour beaucoup des
des enjeux qui sont les nôtres à
l'avenir climatique migratoires il faut
un gouvernement européen et lues par par
les peuples européens ça tomberait
presque impossible aujourd'hui de se
mettre d'accord sur ces questions là est
ce que pour vous aujourd'hui l'europe
est dans une impasse l'europe et et
aimante et déjà non non non l'europe est
pas morte sa configuration
technocratique actuelle badley
indéniablement c'est à dire que c'est
une europe qui n'est pas politique mais
elle n'est faite que de concertation et
de négociations entre les états les ipes
de confédération négocier ça prend un
temps fou dès qu'il ya un problème c'est
des mois et des mois de négociations
entre les différents états et du coup le
problème n'est pas résolu le problème
s'aggrave à la crise grecque par exemple
la crise des migrants enfin d'autres
sujets ces trois dernières années donc
clairement il y aurait beaucoup plus
d'efficacité à avoir un gouvernement en
place et lui et qui travaille dès le
début sans avoir systématiquement le
quitus de tel ou tel état
donc nous on milite pour ça pour pour un
fédéralisme alors qu'ils soient nés sans
quelque sorte avec six sept huit pays
qui veulent bien se jeter dans cette
bataille là et puis et puis à terme on
verra mais s'est refondée l'europe sur
cette base là quoi alors même que
d'autres qui sont très européen et je
leur fais pas de procès de ce point de
vue là
sont peut-être pas suffisamment
fédéraliste les forces vos militants vos
soutiens dans le département sont tous
tournés vers ces européennes
oui la grande majorité des centristes à
lui des ihm et ailleurs on va dire je
pense à nos anciens camarades
effectivement radicaux qui ont été
qui se sent un peu éloigné à l'évidence
des européennes est un son teint un
scrutin qui intéresse le centre tout
particulièrement je rappelle que les
dernières élections européennes dans le
département la liste modem udi donc
unifiée une fois n'est pas coutume avait
fait près de 16 % quand même dans le
département ce qui n'est pas anodin
quand elle était menée à l'époque qu'à
l'échelle régionale par madame de sarnez
et voilà donc quand les centristes parle
d'europe je pense qu'ils savent de quoi
ils parlent
c'est quand même la famille politique
fondatrice jean-monnet enfin ça c'est
quand même de cette famille politique
émerge des pères fondateurs de l'europe
ce sera sa priorité pour les prochains
mois quelles seront les relayeurs
étaient sinon de l'ue dei dans le
département jean tout à fait dans le
département en terme de thématiques ya
l'europe il ya l'environnement qui sont
effectivement pour nous des enjeux
majeurs
et puis bien évidemment la l'écriture
d'un projet en quelque sorte locales et
départementales il va falloir
faire des propositions aux habitants
concrètes dans les différentes élections
à venir municipal et plus tard
départementales et donc il faut qu'on
ait un projet nous fédération 78 sur ces
sujets-là université d'été ce sera en
septembre ce traitement important oui
oui c'est lui d y est un peu libéré en
quelque sorte actuellement alors même si
on a perdu peut-être en nombre pas tant
que ça on aurait pu penser en perdre
plus effectivement avec des départs des
centristes de monsieur morin et des
radicaux
à les libérer parce que les chapelles
n'y sont plus des lycées du des hymnes
on sait pas les radicaux puces intel
puces intel ce n'est plus que l'idée y
est donc il peut y avoir un débat serein
sans arrière-pensée si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
comment se porte le pays dans les
yvelines justement pour conclure en
termes de militants aussi ben on a
effectivement fait l'objet de
une vraie baisse de militants on était à
peu près 300 on a une centaine à peu
près donc
j'entendais un leader de la droite
locale qui disait que les verts étaient
passés de 9000 à 900 bon voilà c'est pas
diviser par 10 mai s'est divisée par 3
quoi en ce qui concerne udi
malgré tout on compte reconquérir
effectivement avec ce discours assez
direct on est effectivement entre une
droite très souverainiste très
identitaire et un gouvernement
certes avec des valeurs libérales
centriste mais peut-être pas
suffisamment affirmé notamment à
l'échelle européens et alors du point de
vue des territoires nous sommes de
réelles décentralisateur alors même que
le gouvernement pêche un tout petit peu
sur les territoires on l'a bien vu à
plusieurs égards merci paul martinez est
revenu aux éditions du 7 8 sa politique
qui se poursuit
[Musique]
dans un instant je recevrai philippe
brillault le maire du chesnay nous
parlerons du rapprochement de sa commune
avec au concours mais aussi du service
autolib qui s'arrête ce qui provoque la
colère de l'élu pour l'instant retour
sur un autre rapprochement est celui des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine les
représentants des deux instances qui
oeuvrent à une mutualisation des moyens
depuis plusieurs années maintenant
annonce dorénavant vouloir gérer les
collèges main dans la main reportage
c'est l'acte 2 du rapprochement entre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine de
nouvelles compétences seront
prochainement mutualiser la commande
publique et l'éducation avec notamment
une gestion interdépartementale des 214
collège des départements bien entendu il
n'y aura pas de fermeture du collège
bien entendu il n'y aura pas moins
d'effectifs dans les collèges cette
administration centrale ce qu'on appelle
l'administration centrale que la
convergence se fera nous pensons là
aussi que le rassemblement de c2c
direction pourra nous permettre de faire
mieux avec moi
cet objectif a motivé la création de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental en février 2016
actuellement 45% des compétences
départementales sont communes et les
deux collectivités s'inspire l'une de
l'autre
nous avons constaté que le service des
yvelines fonctionner bien qu'il donnait
de bons résultats en tous les cas que
c'était mieux que ce que nous faisons
donc au diable pas de problème nous
adhérons à activity en unifiant ses
nouveaux services les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine veulent rendre
irréversible leur fusion même si le
gouvernement n'a pas rendu d'avis
concernant la création d'une seule
collectivité à nous partons à présent
pour la suite de ce set 8 politique pour
le chesnay avec une réunion qui s'est
déroulé fin juin entre jean frédéric
poisson le président du parti chrétien
démocrate ancien député des yvelines a
le républicain jacques myard lui aussi
ancien député nicolas dupont aignan est
les trois hommes se rassemblent sous la
bannière des amoureux de la france
vous êtes certainement emmanuel macron
sous une seule et même bannière ap hier
soir jean frédéric poisson et nicolas
dupont aignan parler d'une même voix
celle du collectif les amoureux de la
france
lancé en octobre 2017 je maintiens que
le projet du président emmanuel macron
est le plus dangereux
on est connu pour le pays depuis
longtemps il promet la souveraineté il
promet de susciter communautariste
contre une culture qui est la culture
française et qui doit continuer à
irriguer notre pays je pense que les
français recommence à barr conscience
que macro est en train de vendre la
france par morceau de mener à la misère
sociale et surtout de aussi de laisser
une immigration sans fin coloniser le
pays j'ai employé ce terme violent pour
faire réagir mes compatriotes
ils veulent réagir face à une situation
qu'ils estiment urgente et appelle à un
rassemblement de toutes les droites la
horde sauvage et que leur malaise
en présence de jacques mignard mais
avait l'air de maisons laffitte
christine boutin de membres de la manif
pour tous et d'anciens élus du front
national la réunion a rassemblé près de
400 personnes il faut rassembler au delà
des clivages même où j'irai il faut
rassembler la droite des gens qui ont
les mêmes la même façon penser que
debout la france qu'il faut qu'il y ait
différentes parties qui propose
différentes choses s'il ya un parti
unique c'est
ça a plus aucune la politique n'a plus
aucune valeur je crois que
la droite n'a pas intérêt à se diviser
l'initiative prise par nicolas dupont
aignan va certainement dans la bonne
direction
c'est génial c'est ce qu'il faut
autrement on s'en sortira pas les
amoureux de la france présenteront un
programme commun pour les élections
européennes de mai 2019
philippe brillault mer les républicains
du chesnay bienvenue sur son château on
vient de voir le reportage qui s'est
déroulée dans votre commune cette
réunion des amoureux de la france vous
n'étiez pas présent
néanmoins cela souligne la trop
construction qui se déroule à droite
actuellement est ce que vous vous la
voyez d'un bon oeil cette reconstruction
est ce que ça a clarifié un petit peu
aussi les choses aujourd'hui
moi je pense que ce qui est important
c'est que on arrive à trouver les femmes
et les hommes qui vont avoir le courage
de pouvoir prendre les décisions sur ce
qu'attendent les français au quotidien
et je pense que c'est ça qui est
important
est ce que la droite est détenteur de
ces valeurs est ce que le côté social
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
refonte complète de cette politique de
personnes et peut-être pas forcément
deux parties donc effectivement je vois
toutes ces personnes qui travaillent par
des regroupements de partis
je pense que le plus important c'est
d'avoir des regroupements de femmes et
d'hommes qui vont défendre les points
essentiels sur le travail la sécurité
sur les migrants sur plein de choses
comme ça et je pense qu'il ya des sujets
sur lesquels on peut se retrouver voilà
on parle de niveau national au niveau
local aussi à cette construction en tout
cas il ya des tendances qui s'expriment
ne serait ce que pour la présidence des
républicains dans le département est ce
que vous êtes plutôt pierre bédier et
sandra du blanche
moi je suis pour que les républiques les
candidats déclarés et je pense qu'il ya
un lien direct aussi avec le président
national donc où elle est
on a à nouveau tous les vieux tromblons
qui ressortent pour reprendre le pouvoir
où on fait du renouveau je crois qu'il
ya peut-être un peu tout cela
je pense que au décours des élections
elle est remplira ses troupes
ou alors les videra voilà et quel que
soit le président la présidente désignée
vous resterait au sein des républicains
je m'interrogerais très clairement si
pierre bédier devient président des
républicains vous pourriez pas repartir
attendons de voir déjà des résultats
vous êtes venu aujourd'hui pour évoquer
un rapprochement va parler de
rapprochement cette fois ci avec
rocancourt la fusion a été votée par les
deux conseils municipaux ce mariage sera
t'il profitable pour les deux communes à
votre avis vous savez que je suis un
défenseur du mariage donc nous concubine
ion 2 n'est déjà pas mal d'années et
donc il était peut-être nécessaire
contre les deux communes on réalise
officiellement ce qu'on faisait
officieusement les églises sont sur le
chesnay là à s'attendre d'équipements
publics étaient sur le ch nerfs au
concours avait les siens et je pense que
les petites communes telles qu'euro
concours sont asphyxiées financièrement
parlant et je pense que re concours
comme un grand nombre de communes en
france ont pu encore équilibrer leur
budget cette année avec des reports
créditeurs mais quand il n'y a plus de
réserves
il y aura obligatoirement des faillites
donc ça a été quelque part je pense à
facteurs déclenchants facteurs
déclenchants est pas une décision on
arrive en fin de mandat je pense que
c'est une décision qui était attendue
par les habitants
tout le monde se réjouit appartements
aux conserves et effectivement les
fiscalités les l'ensemble en jeu
franchement ça se passe très bien
donc nous avons pris déjà une première
délibération de principe et le 8 octobre
nous devrions prendre la décision
définitive par délibération commune dans
chacune des communes
on transmettra au préfet le préfet
prendra ce maçon arrêtés s'ils le
souhaitent et au 1er janvier
il n'y aura plus de chesnay il n'y aura
plus d'euro concours il y aura la
nouvelle commune le chez nero contre le
chesnay rocancourt le nom est actée déjà
vous allez à solliciter les citoyens
aussi peut-être vous savez c'est comme
quand la maman est enceinte on a déjà
des prénoms
on a déjà le prénom
le chesnay davantage pour pour votre
commune c'est aussi de rattraper un peu
le retard sur les logements sociaux
n'ont pas tout à fait c'est à dire que
nous avons chaque trois ans un plan
triennal
bon donc chacune des communes hors
concours de genève et son plan triennal
la seule chose c'est qu'avec la nouvelle
commune il ya plus de référence au plan
triennal donc a priori les arrêtés de
carence ne devrait plus perdurer à
partir du 1er janvier 2020
par contre nous aurons une triennal de 3
en 2020 2021 2022 pour notre nouvelle
commune en cumulant l'ensemble des
logements sociaux que nous avons à faire
et oui c'est quelque chose que nous
allons garder ensemble et mutualiser
l'ensemble des terrains ou des
constructions possibles pour ce faire
mais on a de bonnes idées pour les
habitants quels sont les changements qui
seront palpables réel blanc lorsque la
fusion sera actée alors les
interrogations des habitants
1 est ce que la fiscalité va changer non
puisque nous avons douze ans pour
éventuellement harmoniser les fiscalités
tels des deux fiscalité qui vont
cohabiter pendant une douzaine d'années
maximum qu'ils peuvent on va monter un
budget l'année prochaine où a priori on
appellera peut-être mêmes fiscalité de
part et d'autre il n'y a pas une
mutualisation de cette fiscalité dès le
1er journée ça c'est le premier point et
puis on attend la réforme de taxe
d'habitation qui conditionnera peut-être
tous donc sur la fiscalité aucune
inquiétude
ensuite air au concours toits vont
bénéficier de tous les avantages des
équipements publics que les chesnaysiens
ont financé depuis des décennies donc
quelque part au concours en venant va
avoir une belle dot et nous on aura une
dot effectivement peut-être par un
foncier qui va se faire donc voilà je
pense que harmonisation des tarifs
harmonisation pour le stationnement
ouverture de tous les équipements
publics du chineur au concours toi
ouverture pour les chaînes et zients
d'équipement draw concours non
franchement c'est tip top et qui pour
diriger cette commune alors il y aura au
1er janvier a nommé un nouveau conseil
municipal donc les deux conseils
municipaux actuels vont se réunir avec
le même nombre d'adjoints potentiel et
on refera une élection du maire
des adjoints des délégations sachant qu'
il y aura une commune délégués pour au
concours puisque chacune des communes
qui fusionne peut avoir sa commune
délégué donc une comédie d'éric délégués
pour au concours
le chesnay n'en prend pas et on aura
donc un nouveau maire qui sera et élire
[Musique]
votre question voilà donc a priori si
les élus de nos groupes nous font
confiance jean-françois penry
deviendrait le premier adjoint de cette
nouvelle commune serait le maire de la
communauté de la commune délégué de
rocquencourt et éventuellement
j'assumerai la la la responsabilité en
tant que maire de cette nouvelle commune
et nous aurons l'occasion bien
évidemment de suivre ce dossier et les
dossiers qui ne manquent pas pour votre
commune au début de cette période
estivale il ya aussi votre colère contre
eux ce service autolib service de
véhicules partagés qui va disparaître
c'est un vous avez lancé un collectif
avec 98 communes dont la vôtre qui
bénéficiaient de ce service est ce que
les choses s'améliorent les discussions
au lieu est ce que vous en savez un peu
plus sur le calendrier de leur retrait
des voitures à partir le monde sait rien
depuis des années il n'y a pas de raison
qu'on sache quelque chose de plus
aujourd'hui la mise en place vous n'avez
jamais été associé sollicité rien alors
nous avons reçu un courrier d'ailleurs
hier une précisant les choses alors
c'est pas un collectif de 98 communes
il y à la ville de paris + 98 communes
et j'ai lancé un collectif possible pour
les 98 communes
or lorsque nous avons délibéré pour
liquider quelque part au niveau du
syndicat nz cette délégation
on a vu que nous avons eu un vote
politique toutes les communes de gauche
des 98 communes ont voté avec
les représentants de la ville de paris
donc ça a été un vote politique ça m'a
surpris d'ailleurs
donc du coup si la gauche a voté m et
algo que font les communes de droite
bon et bien les communes de droite pour
partie devenues elles vont déjà au moins
quinze ou seize communes qui constituent
ce collectif je peux vous annoncer en
avant première aujourd'hui que nous
tiendront une conférence de presse le
mercredi 11 juillet à paris où nous
allons annoncer nos décisions parce que
les gens pensent que ça y est c'est fini
on va rien faire
nous avons pris un peu de recul pour
voir ce qui allait se décider en ce
moment et nous allons avoir des actions
la ville de paris est en train de se
débarrasser d'autolib parce que
peut-être ça fait liquider les syndicats
qui est embourbé aussi avec vélib donc
quelque part il ya certainement une
manoeuvre politique pour madame hidalgo
pour se débarrasser de vie libre qui va
très mal aussi deuxième fiasco et le
groupe bolloré qui a montré qu'il
essayait de d'être confiants avec nous
parce qu'on défend des mais si on fait
un recours il ne touchera pas son argent
tout de suite donc il est pas favorable
au recours
c'est pour ça que nous sommes relayés ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre et que nous nous
relayons tout simplement nos habitants
pour la dette et ceux qui bénéficiaient
d'autolib qui fonctionnait très bien
il n'y a aucune raison d'arrêter tout
cela donc on va présenter effectivement
la semaine prochaine un plan a plan de
bataille
un plan de bataille d'une part pour
limiter la dette deuxièmement pour dire
quels sont les responsables de tout cela
et troisième point de pouvoir par
rapport aux stations qu'on a installé ne
pas les brader et utiliser quelque chose
pour favoriser les voitures électriques
des textes rien à voir à nouveau service
en place alors on a vu dans les journaux
psa renault tout le monde se présenter
sur le free floating dans free il ya
beaucoup de liberté la liberté ça aussi
un cadre juridique dont toutes les
communes qui avons financé des stations
il n'est pas question on brade tout ça
bien au contraire nous allons aussi
accueillir peut-être les solutions
alternatives du partage et des véhicules
propres
parce que sinon solder ce soc
thème d'autolib aura un coût pour les
habitants de votre commune tels que
cette pour tous ceux qui ont
effectivement des stations mais
normalement le déficit devait être
absorbées à la fin de la délégation n'a
pas laissé le temps d'une part de
prendre des décisions pour améliorer et
on n'a pas pris des décisions pour que à
la fin d' allégations nsa donc les
responsables de l'anticipation de la fin
de la délégation ont des comptes à
rendre
nous avons un certain nombre d'éléments
juridiques pour ce faire on les prépare
et le 11 juillet on va lancer tout cela
et nous suivrons bien évidemment aussi
ce dossier merci philippe baillot est
revenu en plateau salon refermer ce 7,8
politique prochaine édition ce sera à la
rentrée
l'actualité d'ici là est à suivre dans
les éditions quotidiennes du journal
très bonnes vacances
[Musique]